>>Female Presenter: Hi everyone, I'm Winnie
Lam. Thank you so much for coming. It's my
pleasure to welcome Dr. Iain Douglas-Hamilton
to Google for a talk today. So Iain has started
saving the elephants probably before most
of us were born, looking at the room, certainly
before I was born and before my parents were
married. He has been saving the elephants
and working with local African people on conservation
efforts. He got his PhD in zoology from the
University of Oxford in England and has received
many international awards recognizing him
as a leading authority on African elephants.
Now, let me tell you a couple of interesting
things about Iain. So, he's a pilot in addition
to being a conservationist, he flies his plane
around a lot to track elephants. In addition
to flying his plane he's also crashed his
plane a number of times.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: And this is one of the times
when he's crashed his plane. Luckily, for
the many times, actually not that many, for
the few times that he's crashed his plane,
he's managed to walk away from it safe and
sound and he's with us, so lucky for us and
lucky for him. Another interesting thing about
Iain is that he's Scottish and he likes to
wear his kilt on special occasions. I'll show
you a picture here. He was receiving an award
and he was wearing his Scottish kilt. And
depending on your opinion, it might be fortunate
or unfortunate for us that he's not wearing
a kilt today.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: Anyways, without further ado,
please help me give a very warm welcome to
Dr. Iain Douglas-Hamilton.
[Applause]
>>Iain: Okay, it's amazing to be here at Google.
When I first came across Google Earth, it
just captured my imagination in a way that,
I didn't believe such a thing that I might
have dreamed about, had actually been created.
And since then we've had a wonderful relationship
with Google Earth outreach. I want to thank
very much, Charlie Knowles, who is my host
on many occasions while I conservation network
which is an amazing outfit that helps introduce
conservation entrepreneurs to very large donors.
Without taking anything on the way, they empower
us to carry on our work in Africa. Also, I'd
like to acknowledge George Wittemyer, where
are you George? Oh, there he is, George Wittemyer
and Jake Wall. George is our scientific chairman
of our advisory board of “Save the Elephants"
and Jake is our Programmer and our Database
Manager who looks after all our moving elephants
which, as you will hear, appear on Google
Earth. My theme today is elephants in peril
because we're actually having an unprecedented
surge at the moment in illegal killing of
elephants for ivory. We've come out of a twenty
year lull period where we had a total ivory
trade ban. But now, once again, there's a
rapidly increasing demand that is fueling
illegal killing and seizures of illegal ivory
reached an all time high in 2011. So did another
measure of illegal killing which is part of
the CITES Treaty which, in turn, is part of
UNEP that looks after endangered species.
In some ways history's repeating itself and
I wanna take a minute just to go back to how
I got started which was a long time ago in
1965. I went to live in a small park in Tanzania
called Lake Manyara and I was very lucky to
work up a relationship with about 500 relatively
habituated elephants and to learn to know
them as individuals. By the end of my time
I was working with 50 families but it was
at that time I really learned to respect elephants.
And, in fact, I don't think anyone knew before
that elephants, truly speaking, are a matriarchy
and I learned the meaning of matriarchy; an
undaunted female intelligence who will go
all the way out to save her family. That's
just what you're seeing here. This elephant
is actually charging out in front of her family
while her family escapes, confronting the
danger, which in this case was me.
[Laughter]
>>Iain: I wasn't much of a danger but
>>Iain: she didn't know that. And, unfortunately,
because of this behavior, when female elephants
come out to defend their families, they are
often the first victims. I want to show you
a little piece of natural history before we
get onto other reasons for elephants being
peril. This is a lone female who's defending
her baby against hyena attack, picture taken
this year by someone called James Wells in
Botswana. And the hyenas are closing in on
her baby from all directions and she's out
there defending, kicking with her feet, chasing
them, scuffing up the dirt and at the end
of the day because of her very vigorous defense,
the baby was safe although, unfortunately,
it lost its tail in the process. She's triumphant.
Anyway, I lived, for these 5 first years of
my career, and I'm sorry I'm not telling you
about it because that's the nice part of things
is living with elephants. And I brought up
my family there, my two little girls, and
at the end of the 60's it was the end of an
era, a golden era for the national parks,
a golden era for the elephants. And I became
in a new problem, involved in a new problem,
this is how history is repeating itself, that
the price of ivory suddenly, inexplicably
soared upwards in 1969, '70, '71. Now, in
retrospect, we know that it was caused by
a surge in prosperity in Japan where ordinary
people could all of a sudden afford to buy
ivory and it led to an ivory rush. So my next
phase is I went out on a trip across Africa,
funded by the New York Zoological Society,
to go and find out how many elephants there
were in Africa. And it took me to every corner
of Africa, went in an airplane and to cut
a long story short, the ivory trade was out
of control, the elephants were decreasing
fast and we came across scenes like this.
Of whole families shot down with empty cartridge
cases and one worst case scenario, this particular
herd were 150 survivors out of a population
that had been 8 thousand, five years earlier,
just South of the Nile, so these things did
happen, they can happen. And it was in East
Africa we saw the worst wipe-outs and recorded
them. Masses of ivory were leaving the continent.
It took a very long time to get concerted
international action. So something like, something
the order of 700 thousand elephants went out
in 10 years represented by about 700 tons
of ivory a year. Then, in 1989, Kenya the
country which I live in now, took the lead
and they took the ivory stockpile and they
sent the whole thing up in smoke as a statement
to the world that they were no longer gonna
deal in ivory under the carpet. And this actually
didn't, twenty years of cease fire, we were
great beneficiaries of this. I was able to
go back to what I really love which is studying
elephant behavior, training up local people
to do it and engaging scientists, young scientists
from abroad like George Wittemyer, to come
out and make it a life's work as well. And
in Samburu, where we have our current research
station, it's the most fabulous place you
can imagine. It's a place where, until recently,
elephants could live out their lives without
being dominated by one emotion, which is fear
of man. And so they behave naturally and it's
there that our prime technology was a very
primitive one which was to learn to recognize
elephants as individuals, to record all the
births and deaths and departures. We got to
know, again, about 500 elephants and we have
been monitoring them for 15 years now, in
detail. However, the system did not work well
to tell us how far the elephants went out
of the protected area and how they took their
decisions to move. And for this we turned
to radio tracking using GPS technology. Each
of these collars is a different type of ones
that we've been deploying and they gather
the information on a chip and then send it
out either by satellite or GSM telephone.
Here's an elephant coming to inspect the collars.
And the system, it now operates, we either
download by a satellite or by a telephone
and it goes into a database which was designed
by Jake Wall sitting in the back there. I'm
not going to go into all the details but the
main feature is that it's recording the movements
of hundreds of elephants simultaneously, it
goes into a database which for the moment
is on a server in a local cell telephone company,
we're gonna move it onto the Cloud quite soon
and it can then relate, it can send out text
messages to mobile telephones or to hand held
devices or to the internet. And what Jake
has been developing for us is a series of
algorithms to detect changes in elephant behavior.
This is very exciting and particularly in
relation to the current poaching surge that
is going on. So I wanted to give you a little
example of an elephant in peril. This is an
elephant called Mountain Bull and he lives
under this beautiful mount in Mount Kenya
which is 17 thousand feet high, right on the
equator in the middle of Kenya. He has lots
of difficult choices he has to make that involve
taking risks driven by the imperative to pass
on his genes, he has to go and find females.
And sometimes because he needs to eat good
food and grow strong so that he can compete
with other males for females, he has to take
risks. And unfortunately this sometimes causes
a clash with people. So the little film excerpt
I'm going to show, it's with my daughter who
once made films for the BBC and it is the
story of following in the tracks of Mountain
Bull as he goes up this special corridor,
up onto the heights of Mount Kenya.
[Birds chirping]
[Music plays]
>>female #1 on video: 50 miles south of the
reserve, Saba is hot on the trail of Mountain
Bull.
>>Saba: Fresh tracks.
>>male on video: Fresh tracks, yeah.
[Music plays]
>>female #1 on video: The data shows she's
just days behind.
>>male on video: [inaudible]
>>Saba: We can go straight through the wheat
fields
>>male on video: Yeah
>>Saba: and around the base of that hill in
the distance.
>>male on video: Yeah
>>Saba: And then he runs the gauntlets through
the shambles. So we're dead on course.
>>male on video: Yeah, we're on track.
>>Saba: Right through the wheat.
[Laughs]
>>female #1 on video: Saba's found Mountain
Bull is eating crops and damaging fences,
that isn't going to go down well with the
farmers.
[Music plays]
>>female #1 on video: Back at camp, Saba's
returned. She's telling Iain what she found
out about Mountain Bull.
>>Saba: This is very interesting seeing where
he went, straight through the wheat fields
like we thought.
>>female #1 on video: Saba's seen firsthand
what Mountain Bull is up against. The wheat
farming is on a vast scale so Saba thinks
the farmers are prepared to put up with a
few elephants.
>>Saba: Where I started getting a a bit of
concern from him is where he's coming to the
village because as the human population grows
there and people will encroach more and more
into that area and they won't be quite so
tolerant of Mountain Bull.
>>Iain: So we've got to find a solution.
>>female #1 on video: There's a valley that
runs into the forest avoiding the villages.
If Mountain Bull and the others could be diverted
here using a fence it could solve the problem.
>>Iain: Then you'd be into the sanctuary of
the local forest.
>>Saba: Without bothering the local community.
It seems like a very neat solution.
>>female #1 on video: Using the collars data
and with collaboration from local farmers,
the conflict could be stopped. Mountain Bull
has proven to be clever and adaptable and
the team will keep tracking him to check he's
safe.
[Music plays]
>>Iain: So the corridor is created up the
side of the mountain and it had to pass under
a main road which is the road here, and we
were wondering how long it would take the
elephants to learn how to use this corridor
and to stop using that destructive route.
Well, the curious thing is, the first day
that that corridor was opened, these young
elephants came through, they came under that
tunnel and actually the very first elephant
to come through was one that carried one of
our collars on it. We're very excited about
that. And Google Earth helped us to create
that instantaneous tracking system. This shows
the corridor with the background of the mountain.
And the blue line is where the corridor was
put and it's got a fence on either side. Now,
the green animal there is an elephant called
Tony which was the first elephant that came
through. But the red line is the migration
route of Mountain Bull, who you've already
seen. And he wasn't gonna change quite so
quickly. Now that the younger bulls were using
the corridor, the question was would Mountain
Bull ever learn? So we went on tracking him
and this little movie shows his movements
as he comes towards the corridor. Now, he
broke in half way and came down the corridor
and then he actually couldn't get out because
he found himself surrounded by a whole lot
of fences. And he has to get under that main
road. He has to get under that underpass.
It takes him quite awhile to find a way. He's
trying one route and there he's through.
[Laughter]
>>Iain: So he went through and he went rushing
down to some farms to look for some ladies
[Laughter]
>>Iain: And he couldn't find them and then
he goes back. He hits a fence which thwarts
him and then eventually he goes back again
and he's on his old route and he breaks in
to the corridor and he exits it from the top.
So there's an amazing piece of data, I couldn't
believe it. He'd used the whole corridor but
in a very unorthodox way.
[Laughter]
>>Iain: Anyway, I was gonna show you some
live tracking because the beauty of the system
that we've now got is that we can actually
look from here or California or China or wherever
the hell you like and you can see what's happening
to the elephants in real time. So it is amazing.
We open up our Google Earth and automatically
these files spring out at us. We got, we're
tracking about 60 animals across Africa. This
is all stuff that Jake has written and it's
a tiny little file that it's so easy to send
to someone on email and it points into our
database and also Jake's managed to figure
out how to make everybody's Google Earth automatically
update with the latest status. You not only
get the latest position of each elephant coming
up but if we put a collar on a new elephant,
it'll pop up in your Google Earth. The beauty
of the system is that without any GIS training,
I can give it to anyone in Africa and we're
sharing it now far and wide, we're sharing
our data with people who can actually help
to save the elephants. We're doing it in all
sorts of different ways and we're using it
to detect if an animal starts moving too slowly.
There's an algorithm that immediately says,
"This animal is going below its average speed."
Now, it then pops up and we get an email report
every day with all the elephants on it and
we have automatic alarms against each elephant
and we see whether the collar has failed to
report and if so, for how many hours or days,
we see if the elephant is moving too slowly
and several times when that has happened,
we've alerted a team that's gone out and sure
enough, the elephant is wounded. And then
we get a veterinarian to come and dart the
animal, put it down, give it drugs, clean
out the wound, put it back on its feet. But
our most serious alarm of all is the immobility
alarm. So if the animal stops moving all together
we get a warning and then we send out a patrol
and either the collar has fallen off the elephant
or the elephant has been killed. At the moment
we're trying to hone this down. This is very
much a system under development. We're experimenting
with accelerometers now and we've actually
deployed our first accelerometers at Disney
in Florida. And a Disney scientist then came
out to us and we've been working in the field.
We had an accelerometer on two elephants and
we got a 48 hour cycle. So we were able to
look at what signal we're getting when the
animal lies down and we want to actually get
it so sophisticated that we can tell the difference
between lying down and being dead. Because
elephants do lie down, they lie down on their
side, they go to sleep and they do it probably
twice a night, but if an elephant doesn't
move for 3 hours that's very worrying. So
our automated alarm is graduated, if you get
to a grade 3, that means no movements in 3
hours, that's bad. If it's a 4 or a 5, you
get extremely worried and you send out a patrol.
So these are the various ways we can help
them. And I just wanna show you the areas
where we work in Africa. We're working on
elephants in the desert out in Mali to the
far west near Timbuktu, we're looking at elephants
in the bushveld in South Africa and we're
looking at elephants In Kenya. And we've been
looking at elephants in the Central African
Forest but they've now, that was doing it
with Wildlife Conservation Society and they've
now stopped working. But what is interesting
is that in all these regions the elephants
cross boundaries. So normally, in Africa,
you have to go through huge rigmarole to get
permission to dart an elephant and launch
a tracking operation. So we're actually operating
some illegal tracking operations in a number
of countries because the elephants just walked
across the boundary and they don't know the
difference. Just to show you quickly, this
is the Kruger National Park which is one of
Africa's great parks. And on the left we've
got females in two separate populations, on
the right we've got males. And the colors
were put in three different areas to the north
in this grey blue, to the east in this light
blue and to the west. And we call this the
Trans-boundary elephant project because our
objective is to see how much elephants cross
boundaries, whether they go out of a national
park into a private place or if they go across
a border. So these elephants, the blue ones,
go right deep into Mozambique, they also go
north up into Zimbabwe, very interesting and
very important for their future that we safe
guard these migration routes and the corridors
that connect them. So to the west we have
elephants in the extreme desert country around
Timbuktu. And they live right at the very
edge of existence. Their problem is mainly
to do with finding enough water and finding
enough to eat, it's an extremely harsh environment
and they have the longest migration in the
whole of Africa. They have to get from one
oasis to another. I'm afraid the next maps
not gonna work but they do have a critical
place that they need to go through once a
year, it's called the gates of the elephants,
in French, les portes des éléphants and
it's a nick point where there's a range of
high hills and we have really highlighted,
through our radio tracking, how vital this
corridor is for them. Here you can see the
gate in the background and that little square
zooms into an elephant herd that's making
this lonely migration through that vast area.
Jake is writing his thesis currently and this
is the map that he's made of the movements
of the elephants. They happen to be the longest
migrating elephants in the whole of Africa.
We found out that they go roughly a distance,
cumulative distance of about 4 thousand kilometers
in a year. But what he's found here and it's
very interesting is that blue, those are the
movements of males where only males go and
red is where only the females go and green
is where they share in common. So it really
highlights some interesting biological problems
there, to try to understand why the males
and the females have slightly different ranges.
Well, the main problem, as I said, that we're
dealing with now is not, at the moment, the
alienation of land by human beings expanding
into elephant range, that is a problem but
our major short term problem is the problem
of elephant poaching for ivory. I'm sorry
to show you this picture, it's horrible, but
this is the result of a wounded elephant that
has come back into the reserve having gone
outside, been shot at for its ivory, she's
a matriarch convulsing in agony and we're
seeing more and more of these horrible sights
of animals not just dead but also badly wounded
for the first time in our central reserve.
I'm not gonna show you the rest of it; they
had to put it out of his misery. But I want
to show you another example here is an elephant
called Khadija who's a matriarch. She's the
only one left of her family, all the other
matriarchs are dead and we found her like
this shortly after we had a visit, actually,
from some Chinese guests that we'd been showing
around. And you can see in her shoulder there's
three holes there and she had more bullet
holes elsewhere.
[Coughing in audience]
>>Iain: So we decided that the only thing
we could do for her because she was so badly
wounded was to actually immobilize her and
put her down with a drug and then to treat
her wounds. And here you see her down and
she's been treated but now the problem was
to get her back on her feet. And our team
struggled and struggled and they could not
get her up because she was lying on her bad
leg. So eventually they had to pull her over,
using the car, onto her other side and then
she was able to get back and struggled back
onto her feet. And all through this operation
the little orphans who were the survivors
of the other dead mothers were watching this
process. Well, we tracked this all on our
Google Earth cause we put a collar on her
just to see what was happening. This was the
height of the poaching last year and for 18
days we tracked her going down to the river
and back from the 24th of June to the 13th
of July. And then, sadly, our informers rang
us up and told us they'd heard gun shots.
The next day we went out and we found Khadija
dead. Now it's all very depressing but I'm
showing you this, not because it's exceptional
but because it's become quite common place
to a population that was formally in a really
safe haven. This is my team with some of the
Kenya Wildlife service rangers. They're looking
at the collar they recovered and the poachers
tried to put it out of action by shooting
it with a bullet, so you can see it's all
cracked. Actually, it didn't stop it from
working, it's quite tough. But they buried
it under sand and still it went on working.
Now, I was warned not to show you any graphs
but I'm gonna show you a graph.
[Laughter]
>>Iain: This is a graph, again, it's rather
depressing, what its showing is the wounding
rate in our population from 1998 up to 2011
with the first part of this year, too. And
the light colors there are wounds caused by
traditional forms of human predation, through
spears and arrows but the dark is gunshots.
So you see there a whole trend of what's happening.
If you look at the population itself using
this individual ID system, and this is George
Wittemyer's work, you see here the line at
the top, that's the total size of the population.
So it went from 450 up to about 610 peaking
in the year 2008 before coming down. And here
underneath you've actually got the dark color
is births and the light color is deaths. So
the first part of that, the first decade,
I'm sorry, births exceeded deaths and the
population went up. Then, in 2008 we had a
terrible drought accompanied by elevated levels
of poaching and the elevated levels of poaching
continued. Now we think that what we're seeing
there in our special study site which is one
of the best places for doing this, it's a
microcosm what's happening in Africa and if
you look at the overall population, in 1970
in our area numbers plummeted in that first
round of elephant poaching. Then the elephants
recovered now they are possibly beginning
in another period of plummeting. So we think
this is being replicated further around. And
these are some other populations where the
illegal level of killing has gone up as well.
To get back to the continental scale, this
map of Africa is on a new website that we're
putting together actually funded by the Tides
Foundation through Google Outreach. And the
circles there represent the size of various
elephant populations. So you can see the biggest
by far is found in Botswana and Zimbabwe down
here and then again in Tanzania and all the
other populations are relatively small in
Africa. If you look at this program called
MIKE, Monitoring Illegal Killing of Elephants,
we have these 30 odd sites across Africa and,
I think its 40 sites actually, and here I've
color coordinated them according to the severity
of the poaching. Red is really bad, green
is good. So green means they illegally kill
a small proportion and red means they're very
high. So if 80 percent of the dead elephants
you find are illegally killed you get a deep
red and the yellow is in between. So that
was a period which was 2002 to 2005. Now,
if you look at the situation today you've
got far more reds and the only places which
are free are three populations in Southern
Africa, a couple in the center and that one
in the far west in Mali. That was last year,
this year there's been a series of massacres
of which one of the worst was this massacre
that took place in Cameroon where it was thought
something like between 300 and 500 elephants
were shot. And these are some pictures that
came in from the bush. Sometimes, of course,
we find that it's one of our collared elephants
that gets killed. Well I, I just want to end
on the solutions for the future. One of the
solutions is obviously to lure demand in the
consuming countries, particularly in China.
But another solution is to get local people
on the site in Africa. And we've geared our
whole program to that where we have an outreach
program and people who want to adopt the conservation
option get all sorts of benefits whether from
eco tourism or from improved security in their
area. What you're looking at here is some
volunteers, the people who help us with our
research program to gather information on
poaching. And in Africa a lot of this begins
under a tree where people get together and
they talk. And actually it's a lengthy process
to get everybody on site but we've found that
we've been encouraged by this one thing that
is improving which is an increased level of
local support. And I think in our area if
we can combine that with increased anti poaching
measures, that's why I'm here raising funds
to try to get the wherewithal to combat the
poachers, we can probably beat the poachers
at their game. Symbols are also important
and recently Kenya burnt some ivory that was
an illegal confiscation and made a statement
that they're not going to participate. So
everybody now agrees that its demand that
is driving the trade. On the eco tourism site,
we can give benefits to local people, this
man who's called Bernard, he's a chief guide
at my wife's ecotourism camp which is called
Elephant Watch and if you want some brochures
on that we've got them available here. But
if livelihoods can be given from the elephant
to people that is gonna be one of the keys
to survival. Many of these local people now
are getting new livelihood, the whole expertise
and they're becoming the future guardians
and elephant experts for the future. Finally,
if we're gonna beat this poaching, we need
all individuals, concerned individuals, NGOs
and governments to join together and to settle
any differences, to tackle what is really
a very urgent problem. If the logic is accepted
that we should lower demand for ivory then
it follows that any proposals that come up
from time to time under CITES to trade in
ivory should be looked at in the light of
whether or not they're going to encourage
demand or decrease demand. I think technology
can help save the elephants and other species
and that Google Earth is fantastic tool that
we're using and other people are using in
the conservation field. I just want to now
ask all conservation bodies, all concerned
individuals, all NGOs and all governments
to help with the elephants, to prohibit any
more trade in ivory and to try to get the
means together to allow us to coexist with
this magnificent creature. It's a race to
get new Chinese thinking before it's too late.
It's a race that's got to be won and I want
to leave you with that thought. My last slide
is one that makes me feel happy, it's a huge
bull elephant, he's called Morambo he lived
in Tsavo, he lived out his natural life span
and it's an incredible tribute to the protection
that he received in a difficult time and to
his own wily ways of keeping out of sight
of the poachers. So finally, I just welcome
you if you come to Kenya come and visit us,
come see the elephants and I can very much
recommend my wife's camp unashamedly.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
>> child #1: Why do we need ivory so bad?
>>male #1: Why do we need ivory so bad?
>>Iain: We don't really need ivory, it's a
lovely substance and people make pretty ornaments
out of it but it's not something we need at
all and certainly not if it's killing the
elephant. If people were only taking the ivory
from elephants that die naturally, it wouldn't
matter, but they don't. See, every time you
get a little bit of trade then the poachers
come and they kill the elephant to make money,
they do it just for money.
>>female #2: So you seem to have real time
tracking data for the elephants, how do you
make sure this doesn't get into the wrong
hands, like the poachers?
>>Iain: We don't share it with them.
[Laughter]
>>Iain: We hope we don't share it with them.
We have a public website now which has got,
how long is the delay Jake?
>>Jake: Not telling.
[Laughter]
>>Iain: Not telling, okay.
>>Iain: There you go, you see? Pretty secure.
But we also, we share the real time data with
people who can really make a difference so
our colleagues who are either involved in
conservation right out there in the field,
we now share that a lot. We share it with
people who can be trusted not to pass it on.
But you're absolutely right, poachers are
now sophisticated enough to get a computer,
to log on and to find out where the elephants
are. Some of you have been aware right from
the beginning.
>>female #2: In Rwanda there was the crisis
with the mountain gorilla and the way that
they tackled that problem, same thing poaching,
they were dying almost to extinction and they
took the poachers with political will and
a lot of conservation energy, they made them
the people who take tourists to see mountain
gorillas so you kind of turn the incentive
instead of to track the mountain gorillas
to kill them you track them to take people
to them and make the money worthwhile, more
worthwhile then if they poached. So is that
something that's being explored?
>>Iain: Yeah I think that you said one thing
you put the finger right on it. The only way
you're going to save the elephants is having
the political will to do it. And that will
has got to be everywhere from China to an
elephant range state but the interesting thing
is we went China two years ago and we were
hosted by the China Wildlife Conservation
Association. They took us to the wild Chinese
elephants, I didn't know there were any wild
elephants but there are and they really look
after them so well, as well as they look after
their pandas. So that appreciation was there
and I just don't think that people in China
are dimly aware of what their buying does
in Africa and it's a matter of raising awareness.
So we've got a campaign going on there too
that we're joining other NGOs. But in Africa,
some kind of benefit must come to people to
enjoy elephants and it can be much more than
just purely financial gain, it can also be,
you know, Africa is developing so fast and
the educated class is growing so fast and
they feel very interested about their heritage,
again, they don't see it enough. So I have
to be an optimist and to believe that these
forces are going to win out over the destructive
ones.
>>male #2: Have you, since you have these
marvelous tracking collars that send out telemetry
and you were looking at adding the accelerometers,
have you looked at any technology to add the
ability to collect vital signs from the elephants
and send that out as well?
>>Iain: I wish but we're working on it. I
mean, really, it's cutting edge stuff. And
the difficulty is that somehow you probably
need to get a probe from the collar in subcutaneously
into the elephant or somewhere. I did do some
of that works years ago, we actually measured
the temperature of the blood vessels and this
was back in 1969. We put a thermistor into
a vein and a thermistor into an artery and
got a 10 degree centigrade drop between the
blood coming into the ear and the blood coming
out when an elephant was walking up hill.
I would love to have heartbeat, respiration,
all sorts of parameters and other people do
it with other animals and it's probably just
a matter of time before we can do it with
elephants. We're working with Disney, actually,
on this and we started looking at elephants
reactions to bees because I had a very bright
member of our staff, Lucy King, who was working
out that maybe you could protect crops by
using bees, to make a beehive barrier cause
the elephants are afraid of the bees. So she
tested what they're afraid of and played bee
sounds to the elephants and videoed their
reaction. And the amazing thing was that they
pretty promptly ran away from the sound of
angry bees buzzing. And then she recorded
with our colleague from Disney, Joe Soltis
the rumbles that the elephants made when they
were running away from the bees. First, they
run 30 meters silently and then they'd start
talking to each other. Now that rumble, when
that was replayed to elephants against the
normal rumble, the elephants ran away from
that rumble. It turned out to be an alarm
rumble and they looked at the sound spectrogram
of the rumble and they found there was a little
second reforment which they suspected might
be the alarm component. So they manipulated
that on a computer, removed the formant, replayed
the rumble again and the elephants didn't
run away. So they did some really nice work
and now this accelerometry stuff, I think,
is gonna be a new era and we would love to
look at other things to actually monitor at
the same time.
>>male #4: Is the production of artificial
ivory for curtailing the demand for real ivory?
>>Iain: Not so far but I wouldn't rule it
out. The thing about ivory it's got an internal
structure. There's a very interesting thing
called schreger lines that give it it's quality
and it's beauty and it polishes very beautiful
and however you carve it you've got this internal
structure. Nobody's been able to replicate
that in a synthetic type of ivory but if you
could make good enough expensive synthetic
ivory, why not? Actually when plastic first
came out in the 30's there was a collapse
in the ivory market.
>>female #3: Hello Doctor. So my question
was about the Asian elephants. Are we doing
anything for them or is the situation not
so bad in Asia?
>>Iain: It's bad in a different way. The Asian
elephants are principally running out of space,
particularly in India. But it's very interesting
that the culture in the Indian subcontinent
is much more elephant-friendly and therefore
the elephants have been tolerated despite
exceedingly high human density. Nevertheless,
there has been a great reduction in the tuskers
and in the Asian elephants only the males
have tusks. So the male populations have been
hugely distorted. Practically all the old
ones have been killed. Even in places which
are not supposed to be places that poach,
but there is some poaching going on. So it's
a different situation. Say the elephants would
love to be involved, but we're a pretty tiny
NGO and at the moment we're pretty swamped
with Africa. What we do is one thing we do
is we operate a news service that covers both
continents. We scan all the news that's on
the web, we replicate it and we send people
emails of that news. We share a lot of stuff
that way and I have very good friends who
study Asian elephants and we make common cause
when we go to the big CITES meetings where
people debate whether or not there should
be a limited ivory trade. And the Indians
and our part of Africa were dead against that
idea.
>>Charlie: Okay, well thank you all for being
here. My name is Charlie Knowles; I'm the
founder and president of the Wildlife Conservation
Network. We're based here in Los Altos, and
we're very fortunate to have Winnie Lam here
in Google who got us here and promoted Iain's
talks. Thank you.
[Applause]
>>Charlie: And we'd love to have you more
involved in any way that you wanna be involved.
So we have a Google docs sign up where you
can send us an email to info at wildnet, w-i-l-d-n-e-t
dot org. We have some literature on WCN, we
support 20 organizations working in 30 countries
around the world and there's also information
on "Save the Elephants." And mostly I wanna
thank Iain and his team for the heroic work
you're doing to save elephants for all of
us and for our children and grandchildren,
so, thank you Iain.
[Applause]